[Musique]
bonsoir à ceux qui nous rejoignent pour
cette soirée spéciale élections
municipales après montbéliard place
maintenant au débat consacré à la ville
de lons le saunier la ville préfecture
du jura jacques pélissard le maire rpr
puis ump pu l air depuis 1989 de cette
ville ne se représente pas donc sa
succession s'annonce très ouverte
après 31 ans de mandat voici les
candidats présents sur le plateau
donc pour débattre durant 45 minutes
tout d'abord géraldine revit c'est la
tête de liste divers extrême gauche
d'une liste soutenue entre autres par la
france insoumise john huet lui et du
mouvement radical social et libéral
il conduit une liste divers droite c'est
un ancien adjoint de jacques pélissard
christophe perny conduite une liste
divers gauche ancien socialiste et
ancien référent de la république en
marche pour la ville de lons le saunier
il a été aussi président du conseil
départemental durant quatre ans de 2011
à 2015
christophe bois du mouvement agir la
droite constructive
il a reçu le soutien de jacques
pélissard le maire sortant il est son
adjoint d'ailleurs aux affaires sociales
il a reçu également le soutien de la
république en marche
et puis jean ribes rallye il n'était dès
rendant aucune formation politique
il conduit une liste de gauche avec le
ps le pcf et europe ecologie les verts
pour introduire ce débat de 45 minutes
une première question a été posée donc à
chacun des candidats leur ordre pour
répondre a été tiré au sort pourquoi
vous présentez-vous à la municipale à
lons le saunier vous avez 20 secondes
pour répondre tout d'abord on commence
avec jean-yves ravier madame m héry
bonsoir j'ai toujours été investis sur
la ville de lons le saunier tant au
niveau professionnel qu'au niveau
bénévolat et je suis conseiller
municipal et communautaire
je veux préparer la ville de lons aux
défis de demain je veux préparer la
ville aux défis qui attendent les
générations futures
je veux une ville plus écologique une
ville plus juste une bulle plus
démocratique
je suis fier d'être à la tête d'une
liste de rassemblement de citoyens de
gauche et des écologistes et moi même
qu'il n'ait jamais été encarté dans un
parti politique très bien christophe
bois même question pourquoi vous vous
présenter je suis candidat pour être
maire de lons le saunier car j'aime ma
ville dans ce saunier j'y suis né j'y ai
grandi je vis annonce le saunier je
travaille en se soigner je suis chef de
file d'une liste de rassemblement
chacun ses convictions des hommes et des
femmes qui veulent faire bouger la ville
et dognin me connaissent je suis engagé
associativement je suis un élu local
présent sur le terrain les lédoniens
savent aussi que je suis constant dans
mon travail et j'ai le goût des autres
bon cela je me présente pour être mère
dans ce sommet christophe perny
à vous de répondre à cette question me
dis je c'est une question à laquelle on
ne répond pas seul moi je suis venu dans
cette élection parce que j'ai été
sollicité par un certain nombre de
personnes de personnalités dans la ville
qui m'ont dit l'an sociaux ni après
jacques pélissard a besoin d'un homme
fort à la tête de cette ville et il faut
que tu m eh bien au service de la ville
ton expérience de la gestion du
département
et puis comme tout le monde j'aime ma
ville j'aime la politique et donc ce
rendez vous avec les lédoniens était
d'une certaine manière assez naturelle
pour construire une nouvelle page pour
ouvrir une nouvelle page de l'histoire
de notre ville et c'est pour cela que
celles et ceux qui m'entourent qui
viennent de sensibilités très
différentes
eh bien on souhaitait que je conduise la
liste pour devenir leur mère janet
pourquoi cette candidature déjà type
professionnel je suis cadre des
collectivités territoriales et j'ai été
élu en 2014 maire adjoint en charge des
ressources humaines et des finances sur
la ville de lons le saunier et depuis
2010 est j'ai en charge le développement
économique sur l'agglomération ce qui me
permet d'avoir cette double casquette à
la fois de techniciens et de décideurs
locales et nous avons bâti depuis deux
ans avec une association de citoyens un
projet de rassemblement qui permet à la
fois d'avoir des convictions partagées
et une vision pour notre territoire pour
les dix prochaines années
donc une vision de dynamisme sur notre
territoire une vision
géraldine revit c'est à vous de terminer
ce tour de table
bonsoir alors moi je suis lédonienne
depuis 40 ans donc je suis très attaché
à ma ville et je ne voulais pas que les
colère du peuple lédonien ne soit pas
entendu porté et traduite dans un projet
politique
c'est pourquoi je suis tête de liste
d'une liste citoyenne constitué à 80% de
citoyens non encartés et à plus de 30%
gilet jaune très bien merci beaucoup
alors je signale qu'une autre candidate
est en lice pour cette élection
municipale à lons le saunier johan moral
de lutte ouvrière les statuts les
défendre le camp des travailleurs
après ce tour de table sur les
motivations des uns des autres
je vous propose d'aborder le premier
thème de cette de ce débat la ville de
lons le saunier a perdu de nombreux
habitants en trente ans elle est passée
de 19 mille à dix sept mille habitants
comment enrayer cette chute du nombre
d'habitants on va commencer avec vous
monsieur helvète
quels sont vos projets pour cette ville
pour enrayer cette chute démographique
tout d'abord en stoppant l'hémorragie et
en plus ensuite en faisant en sorte de
regagner la population bon ça a de
nombreux atouts il fait bon vivre où il
fait bon travailler
notre vision elle porte sur trois points
d'une part une activité économique plus
importante des services publics qu'ils
soient préservés et ambitieux une
qualité de vie qui mêle à la fois leur
préservation de l'environnement est une
démarche écologique
tout d'abord sur le développement
économique nous sommes la seule liste
avoir visité l'intégralité des
entreprises depuis deux ans on connaît
leurs problèmes leurs obstacles pour
créer l'emploi on souhaite les
accompagner au créant un guichet unique
sur le notre territoire
j'ai été à l'origine aussi de la
création du campus numérique qui permet
d'offrir des conditions pour des
porteurs de projets qu'ils souhaitent
innover sur notre territoire et on nous
avons enfin un dynamisme commercial sur
le centre ville nous souhaitons
accompagner les commerçants on va
peut-être arrêter là l'énumération si ça
vous dérange pas donner la parole aux
autres candidats qu'ils ont on reviendra
vers vous christophe perny
c'est quoi votre axe de développement
pour dynamiser le centre ville
déjà il faut quand même savoir pour
les savoir d'où on vient et le plan de
table a été plutôt bien fait puisque
merci puisque nos deux amis qui sont ici
eux ont une responsabilité puisqu'il
était au pouvoir il était là pour
décider pour agir et la situation
d'aujourd'hui donc elle ne tombe pas du
ciel elle vient d'une défaillance en
termes de politique locale alors
j'écoute ce que dit john huet sur le
développement économique
je suis assez d'accord avec lui sur le
constat on a un vrai problème de
développement économique puisque depuis
une vingtaine d'années lons le saunier
ne s'est pas créé d'emplois il n'y a pas
d'entreprise convenue sur le constat
n'est d'accord le problème dans ce qu'il
a dit c'est que c'est lui qui s'en
occupait et donc moi je veux bien qu'on
fasse un concert mais quand on était aux
manettes on a une énorme part de
responsabilité parler l'autre
l'autre personne qui se trouve
actuellement dans la majorité sortante
vous qu'est ce que vous en savez que vos
affaires sociales alors vous vous êtes
adjoint aux affaires sociales de jacques
pélissard vous êtes d'accord sur le
constat que vous êtes non vous n'êtes
pas d'accord sur le quota le fait que
lons le saunier et perdu des habitants
effectivement de ça vous êtes d'accord
effectivement depuis trente ans on a
perdu des habitants dans le saunier en
revanche depuis une dizaine d'années on
a stabilisé à 17000 si vous regardez
bien un peu les chiffres ont
effectivement il ya des petites
variations mais nous sommes aux
alentours de 17 mille habitants et
pourquoi on a stabilisé à 17000
habitants
parce que aussi on a des commerces un
centre commercial qui reste assez
dynamique
on n'a pas d'exemple commercial ça veut
dire des centres dix autres villes il
perd ce qui est qui et on a en a remis
des hypermarchés du du commerce en
périphérie ça permet de donner une
attractivité
on a eu des chiffres du chômage qui sont
tombés lundi
nous sommes à 5 5 % de taux de chômage
on peut dire qu'elle en faisait nuit on
est pratiquement au plein emploi sur ces
indicateurs qui sont là et bien ce sont
des forces pour demain et bien quelles
sont ses forces pour demain premièrement
il faut qu'on rénove l'habitable quand
même problématique annonce l'habitat des
habitants ont besoin de se loger
donc il faut rénover de l'habitat qui
est un peu anciens il faut aussi à la
mener un peu plus d'animation animations
au sens large
l'animation s'est aussi bien le commerce
mais c'est aussi ça peut être aussi un
musée ça peut être aussi les termes à
valoriser et enfin il faut accompagner
les porteurs de projets parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut imaginer
un certain nombre de chefs d'entreprise
veulent venir sur lons et donc il faut
libérer ces énergies on finit le tour de
table
monsieur ravier dans les constats il
faut rajouter un autre constat c'est que
le nombre de logements en ville vide sur
la ville de lons le saunier est passé de
400 en 1990 à 1400 actuellement et
deuxièmement le taux de pauvreté sur la
ville de lons et de 20% ce qui fait
qu'il est largement au-delà de la
moyenne nationale brute et 20% ça veut
dire que vous avez 20 % de la population
lédonienne qui vit en dessous du seuil
de chaufferie fournis par l'insee donc
c'est pour moi qui l'inventé
le chief donc ses 900 euros par mois
c'est ça un peu n'est pas soigneusement
il ya promis 400 logements libres après
faut savoir quel était le logement sont
libres donc je la retire lavier et vous
plaît je vous donne la parole après jeu
en grande partie responsable de cette
situation et je crois que la créativité
il faut l'avoir sens large et finalement
il ya l'emploi il ya l'urbanisme il ya
les logements il ya aussi la transition
à cogeco logique en est en place et par
exemple sur l'urbanisme
effectivement il faut avoir une volonté
forte de rénover ces mêmes logements du
centre-ville qui permettront de faire
venir des nouveaux habitants
et bien sûr ça donnera aussi du travail
aux commerçants je compte d'ailleurs
accompagner les commerçants en mettant
en place un manager de centre ville qui
sera la relation entre la municipalité
et le commerce que quelques géraldine
revit vous votre liste a des
propositions à faire à propos des
logements justement alors on a des
propositions à faire que sur les
logements et notamment sur la rénovation
des logements rénovation qui est plus
qu'urgente quand on voit l'état de
délogement à peu près partout sur la
ville avec une vraie menace pour la
sécurité des personnes
moi j'entends ce que dit monsieur bois
je me demande juste puisqu'il était aux
affaires depuis quelques années déjà
pourquoi ne pas avoir engagé cette
rénovation des logements
par ailleurs on se dit que puisque
rénovation des logements il faut alors
autant la faire avec des critères de
respect de l'écologie puisque
c'est une nécessité aujourd'hui par
ailleurs et c'est pas le seul le seul
frein à l'attractivité de la ville de
lons
il ya l'oncle loi les gens ne viendront
pas à lons il n'ya pas l'emploi qui leur
permet d'y habiter
et il est nécessaire aujourd'hui de
faire revenir les usines à lons et puis
il ya le bien vivre et dans le bien
vivre
jan ove code santé et l'offre de santé
sur lons c'est une catastrophe
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire et on a
des propositions monsieur bernier vous
jeu est interrompu tout est là donc je
vous redonne la parole on parle des
conséquences mais pour faire nous on
pense que tout passe par le
développement économique c'est à dire
qu' il n'y a pas eu de moyens mis en
place de compétences met en place il
faut des outils pour faire du
développement économique
parce que le développement économique ce
sont des couples et les couples ils
viennent remplir les logements les
acheter les rénover on peut participer
avec eux les couples ce sont des enfants
en 20 ans je crois qu'il s'est fermé
quatre ou cinq écoles on pourra remplir
les écoles et puis tout ça bien c'est la
vie commerciale
c'est l'avis des associations sportives
culturelles c'est comme ça qu'on fait
vivre une ville or là on a isolé danse
le saunier nous sommes un carrefour
important au niveau géographique et
cette attractivité
je suis d'accord avec un point ce qui a
été dit c'est plein de choses
l'attractivité
c'est effectivement un outil pour le
développement économique ensuite c'est
par exemple des événements moi j'avais
créé lorsque j'étais président les des
boussoles adnot recréeront cela à
l'échelle de la ville c'est-à-dire
budget le budget du département n'est
pas celui de la ville donc on peut pas
faire les mêmes choses mais ce sont
aussi de privilégier effectivement le
coeur de ville et de mettre en place
également des outils
j'aimerais bien aussi que les uns les
autres accompagnements que vous
prononciez parce que christophe bois sur
l'avenir de l'hôtel-dieu l'hôtel dieu
c'est l'ancien hôpital donc été
construit au xviiie siècle bâtiment gris
courts tout est classé monument
historique vous christophe voix vous
voulez en faire un pôle culturel avec un
musée alors pourquoi cette proposition
et combien ça a coûté c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être une jolie idée comme ça
sur le papier pour l'attractivité de la
ville mais qu'est ce que ça va donner
les domiens son propriétaire et en
valeur patrimoine un hôtel dieu ce
bâtiment il faut le sécuriser les devis
sont là il faut 12 millions d'euros dans
les dix ans
ils viennent donc on a deux solutions
soit on le laisse tomber et que ça
devient les forges de baudin c'est pas
notre position soit on le rénove pour
faire une coquille vide
c'est à dire ou à mettre 12 millions
d'euros on va on va restructurer le toit
les ouvrants de l'escalier monumental la
grille que vous venez d'évoquer ou
troisième solution on en fait un hôtel
un pan dans un hôtel on en fait un musée
et pour ce musée on peut être
subventionnée de façon importante dans
le cadre d'un contrat de plan état
région qui peut nous permettre d'obtenir
entre 70 et 80 % de subventions
on a misé sur un musée des beaux-arts à
musée d'archéologie à une vidéo il
aurait plusieurs il aurait plusieurs
chants bien évidemment l'archéologie les
beaux-arts et puis ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la drac a la volonté de faire
de ce musée le troisième musée de
bourgogne franche comté
j'ai déjà avancés çà c'est la drac
l'équipe la direction régionale des
affaires culturelles qui vous pousse à
un peu a utilisé 150 la drac étudie la
première digue de thé dieu parce que
leur objectif c'est aussi de faire d'une
pierre deux coups c'est rénover un
bâtiment qui compte beaucoup pour eux et
le permettra je veux voir active et le
12 et le coup parce que visiblement j'ai
entendu 25 30 millions non non non non
il est actuellement il ya un comité de
programmation qui travaille avec un
objectif de 20 millions d'euros
ce n'est pas me rater un c'est 20
millions d'euros john huet vous de
l'hôtel-dieu vous voulez en faire quoi
le projet estimé celui de autour de 26
millions d'euros avec des subventions
d'investissement certes mais qui ne sont
pas certaine mais c'est surtout le
budget d'exploitation qui est trop
important à faire porter par les impôts
des lédoniens l'affront nous ne s'est
pas notre volonté et notre souhait est
effectivement il ya les atouts des
musées des beaux-arts et d'archéologie
mais que l'on souhaite
joint dans une réflexion globale qui
associe l'hôtel-dieu et l'ancien hôtel
de ville pourrait faire une hôtellerie
de quatre étoiles une cité des savoirs
faire et du terroir avec la filière
comté la filière invitait viticulture
l'office de tourisme
un espace bien-être tout ceci se restera
la propriété de la ville mais en faisant
appel aussi à des investisseurs du jet
combien alors pour vous
le budget ces retours aussi de 20
millions mais qui mêle à la fois des
investisseurs privés puisqu'il y avait
déjà une étude qui avait été mené durant
ce mandat qui avait été abandonnée je
souhaite qu'on souffre qu'on revienne à
ce projet christophe dernier alors nous
on a une toute autre idée on en a on a
réfléchi moi au départ j'étais plutôt
pas favorables c'est cette idée de musée
d'archéologie mais après avoir écouté
les arguments en particulier des du
directeur et des techniciens
je pense qu'il faut faire quelque chose
nous on pense ce n'est pas réaliste de
faire ça dans le des lieux parce que ça
commence effectivement est ce qu'il ya
des écrits quand même et il ya un écrit
qui a 26 ou 27 millions ça va se finir à
parce qu'on connaît comment ça marche et
puis c'est quand même un projet qu'on
nous amène comme ça à deux mois des
élections dans un bâtiment qui a des
centaines d'années donc ça ne se sent
pas un projet qui est construit
sérieusement de nous on est pour faire
un projet d'écologie mais ailleurs et on
est surtout pour faire vivre
l'ancien hôtel de ville qui est juste à
côté donc de l'hôtel dieu avec un vrai
projet pour donner une identité à notre
ville autour de rouget de lisle rouget
de lisle je termine juste j'ai dis juste
pour ceux qui connaît qui connaissent
peut-être pas rouget-de-lisle on a des
jeunes qui habitent sur l'une d'elles en
tête 15 ans ils ont jubilé affaire
sérieuse
voilà c'est le créateur de la
marseillaise elle est originaire de nous
ce sont environ dans le monde entier on
connaît la bande riez et rouget de lisle
et personne ne sais qui les lance
sociaux nés ça vous parle on parle et
d'attractivité tout à l'heure il faut
donner une identité aux territoires par
les deux pour pouvoir faire de
l'attractivité et donc nous on pense que
ce projet là il est prioritaire pour ce
qui est de l'hôtel-dieu moi je pense
qu'il faut poursuivre en tout cas nous
poursuivre les études et on s'engage à
une chose c'est que ça fait 30 ans que
satan ne pas faire attendre plus de 30
mois voilà et de prendre une décision
une année l'appareil des hypothèses
possibles sur l'exploitation de ce site
mais si ravier qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de ces projets là vous avez les
vôtres aussi de ville de lens a des
richesses archéologiques elle a aussi
des richesses dans son centre de
conservation notamment au niveau des
beaux-arts et c'est vrai que nous sommes
fiers de tous ces éléments et il a utile
de les mettre en valeur
c'est vrai que budget le budget du sujet
proposé à 30 millions d'euros ça
m'interpelle parce que c'est quand même
le budget
annuel de la viande 27 on a vu 26 élus
si la zone plus il faut forcément au
niveau des alentours du musée il va
falloir faire des travaux donc en fait
c'est qu'on finira à 30 millions donc
c'est le budget annuel de la ville de
lens il ya une étude de programmation
qui est en cours et moi ce que j'attends
de cette étude qu'elle sait qu'elle nous
donne la somme de l'investissement est
aussi et surtout le fonctionnement parce
que c'est souvent cela qui pose problème
aux collectivités les sommes dues au
fisc
il ya des subventions pour pour
l'investissement et le rapport pour le
fonctionnement et il me semble que ce
projet il ne devrait pas être porté
uniquement par la ville de lens
il faut élargir le tour de table
financier géraldine revit vous qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de tout ça alors
messieurs excusez moi mais je crois que
vous mettez un petit peu la charrue
avant les deux cantons cherchent à se
loger
on s'assure que quand on arrive dans le
logement il soit libre or aujourd'hui
l'hôtel dieu c'est le lieu qui héberge
encore la pharmacie de l'hôpital aux 1er
2e étage le magasin de l'hôpital au sous
sol des salles comme à la salle du
conseil de surveillance et la salle des
instances nous ce qu'on dit c'est qu'on
sera une municipalité qui se battra pour
l'hôpital public qui le soutiendra et
qui donc par conséquent lui laissera le
temps de trouver les solutions pour
héberger ce qui aujourd'hui est à
l'hôtel-dieu ailleurs puisque pour
l'instant l'hôpital de lons n'a pas
communiqué de solutions pour héberger
pharmacie magasins et conseils et salles
des côtes instance et après on
réfléchira à la station possible
consommer travail la langue de bois ou
sur aviez vous avez lecture ce projet
pour faire ça se construit une nouvelle
pharmacie sur l'hôpital effectivement ça
prendra un certain temps mais
prochainement l'hôtel vous pour fermer
les yeux noirs vide exactement mais dans
ce projet que fait-on du magasin et des
contes et des salles des instances
prévues
n'est pas prévu c'est le bâtiment
appartient la commune forcément
l'hôpital sera obligé de le libérer un
coupon moyen terme
là on est en train de parler de saoula
on en a parlé 25 millions 30 millions 35
millions 36 voix l'a annoncé il va nous
la vérité nous ne proposait deux projets
pour 15 millions d'euros
oui mais jamais la drague va aider pour
faire un musée à courlaoux l'objectif
c'est de passer pour du court là où il
séjourne à lillers référé de lons parce
qu'on ne peut pas tout faire sur
l'autriche a entassé entassés entassés
et puis moi je veux voir un ministre de
la culture a qui gérait expliqué
monsieur le ministre nous allons faire
deux musées donc enrichir la culture
dans notre pays et vous allez faire des
économies je veux voir ça 5 secondes que
le ministre va me dire nos allergies
sévères des économies vous rigolez même
si j'aurais essayé mais je connais bien
oui mais c'est pour ça que je lis et est
donc de vos amis il fait partie de vos
amis mais c'est un garçon sérieux et
donc si on lui propose d'économiser
quelques millions j'ai pas l'ombre d'un
doute que le premier ministre du mali
dieu économiques demandent aux citoyens
quand ce qu'ils veulent parce que vous
avez ça justement ces moments là il faut
soumettre des projets aux citoyens il ya
une augmentation de loyer mais les
élections ne peuvent pas être le lieu où
on apporte des projets à bouffer là on
leur propose de choisir entre l'hôtel
dieu
un musée dans l'est tel dieu ou point
que tous vont vous donner tout à fait
laisser rêver on peut donner
on peut donner les grandes intentions
des grandes visions aux citoyens et puis
construire aussi avec eux c'est le
l'objet que l'on veut faire avec des
commissions des consultations citoyennes
des commissions de quartier
mais aujourd'hui on peut donner aussi
des visions c'est l'objet vous faites
des élections municipales aller mais
s'attendent à une étude en cours c'est
normal aussi qu'on attende les résultats
de cette étude pour pouvoir voir
exactement où on peut aller où
si on ne peut pas y aller jamais on a
fera quand même jamais un hôtel parce
que jamais le préfet de région
autorisera d'en faire un hôtel mais
c'est un bâtiment classé mais monsieur
bois ça existe l'hôtel dieu à lyon a été
rénové en hôtel 4 étoiles et en
pépinière d'entreprises à valenciennes
il ya d'autres exemples à saint-émilion
d'asie d'autres exemples et même à
vesoul
aujourd'hui ils sont en train de
travailler sur l'ancien hôpital pour en
faire un hôtel haut de gamme donc c'est
parce qu'elle a besoin juste on va
passer comme au sujet suivant c'est très
important que sur le condamne à vingt
secondes sur ce je connais certains
chrétiens c'est aussi un de mes amis qui
est qu'il est mère de deux bâtiments
n'est pas classé ils vont vider
partiellement plafond mais il va bien a
dit ça mais vous savez je vous donne
rendez vous pour le prochain débat
concernant les élections municipales
avait envie de rider je voulais du sol
au plafond alors je voulais parler de la
fiscalité et de l'éclat alors les
classes et ça rien à voir c'est pas du
tout un éclat de colère c'est l'espace
communautaire l'once agglomération c'est
la structure intercommunale jean
communication que trouvait donc c'est
pour l'expliquer aux grisons en bref
c'est vraiment un champion vous avez
cassé un peu mon effet la mort fin
bosser prague
justement on parlait donc budget grosso
fiscalité la ville de lons le saunier
elle-même se porte bien messieurs
financièrement parlant
mais la structure intercommunale connaît
de grosses difficultés financières il
manque un million quatre cent mille
euros pour boucler le budget est-ce que
est-ce que forcément vous allez être
obligé madame messieurs si vous arrivez
à faire à lons et en tant que peut-être
responsables ou l'un des responsables de
la structure intercommunale obligés
d'augmenter les impôts pour
l'intercommunalité
madame rhji votre avis alors moi je sais
ce que je dis c'est que s'il faut
augmenter les impôts alors il faut
impliquer la population lédonienne dans
cette augmentation
il faut que ce soit la population qui le
décide nous tous les projets vraiment
que les gens vous êtes d'accord pour
payer plus d'impôts madame en faisant
beaucoup de pédagogie
ça dépend de quel projet chauny derrière
ça dépend de quel projet sont mis
derrière
en fait si le projet qui est proposé et
qui validé par la population qui est
choisi par la population est un projet
qui améliorent les conditions de vie des
lédoniens bien sûr que les lédoniens
peuvent accepter
alors monsieur monsieur ravier donc vous
conduisait la liste ps pcf europe
ecologie les verts
si jamais vous est élu maire de lons est
ce que les uns pour intercommunaux
augmenteront
je vous dire si je suis élu maire de
lens il y aura pas d'augmentation
d'impôts sur la ville de lons et je ne
serai pas candidat non plus à la
présidence de l'agglomération
vous voulez pas connus par les deux
parce que je pense que ces deux
fonctions qui mérite quelqu'un à temps
plein avec une charge importante donc ça
c'est très clair
deuxièmement la situation actuelle de
l'agglomération elle est due à monsieur
bois et me suivent et qui étaient aux
affaires actuellement et c'est vrai
qu'on a il nous manque 1,4 million
d'euros pour boucler le budget 2021 là
que la collectivité éclat n'a plus les
moyens de faire de gros investissements
et c'est un vrai problème pour la ville
de lens puisque toute façon on sait très
bien que maintenant les projets
structurants ils se font au niveau de
l'agglomération
la ville elle-même n'a pas les moyens et
n'a pas laissé pour le fait bien même si
ses porte bien il grands projets
structurants
il se porte au niveau des claé
actuellement éclat n'a plus le moyen de
faire ces projets monsieur yvette ou
alors où est ce que vous pouvez répondre
vous en tant que membre donc de cette
structure intercommunale
oui moi j'ai toujours fait preuve de
clarté et d'honnêteté et je l'avais dit
lors du vote des orientations
budgétaires ou les services avaient
mentionné qu'en 2021 il manquerait pour
équilibrer le budget de fonctionnement
de l'agglomération 1 million 400 mille
euros contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur ravier c'est pas dû à une
mauvaise gestion c'est parce que le
gouvernement hollande à baisser les
dotations de l'état et cumulé 1 million
par an et donc sur la mandature sas à 6
millions de manque donc c'est bien de 12
à vue parce qu'on s'est bien battue d'un
million 4 c'est bien au dessus d'un
million 4 donc effectivement il aura à
travailler sur une hypothèse d
d'augmentation des impôts mais nous la à
anticiper sur la ville parce que et je
sais en tant que mère que de lons le
saunier que je raisonne et nous fera
nous proposera une baisse indirecte des
impôts en proposant notamment la cantine
à 1 euro et les transports publics à 12
euros par an là c'est une baisse
indirecte qui dilue qui compensera
largement on finit le tour de table un
tableau à propos de l'intercommunalité
puis après justement passera au
transport et à la main sur un monsieur
bois bon alors j'en faisais mal géré
vous avez mal gérée l'intercommunale il
faut encore m'inscrire en faux sur les
chiffres tout d'abord 136 millions au
lieu de 20 millions et là maintenant on
porte ce sur ce si sûr ce chiffre de 1,4
million d'euros
il vient de quoi sur 4 millions d'euros
c'est une prospective qui a été demandé
à un cabinet d'études pour désendetter
rapidement l'agglomération sisi
exactement avec 3,3 millions d'euros
dans d'emprunt j'ai vu avec la tholot
n'a plus les moyens d'aller famille des
big daddy l'agglo n'a rien d'un merci
merci vous fait pas plaisir mais c est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
chiffre 10 en 10 ans et 6 mois
oui c'est le côté son endettement la
capacité de désendettement
8 on considère que c'est beaucoup oui
ils en sauront nous vient de 12 ans nous
étions à 11,9 année dernière nous sommes
à 10 ans actuellement et nous nous
proposons et moi je propose que l'on
reste à dix ans quel est l'objectif de
désendetter de façon dynamique le éclats
et bien c'est effectivement d'augmenter
sa va augmenter les impôts moi les
impôts c'est du pouvoir d'achat
n'oublions pas en moins pour les
lédoniens et si on en manque un petit
peu les impôts on a augmenté avec éclat
en 2018 le versement transport
on a augmenté après le versement
transport c'est pour les autres mais
sait on aime ces difficultés là et
maintenant ça suffit
il ya donc nous on est sur la possible à
l'hypothèse contiendra on n'augmente pas
les impôts à la ville de se soigner et
ça c'est assez facile mais on
n'augmentera pas non plus des impôts sur
intercours s'est tout simplement imposé
techniquement c'est tout à fait
impossible c'est à dire cela c'est soit
ne pas connaître le sujet et je pense
qu'il connaît le sujet de choix c'est
mentir sciemment parce que et je vais
rappeler une petite chose un christophe
doigt parce que les dix des dix années
ennemis que vous avez indiqué sont
importantes dans la vie d'une
collectivité c'est un peu le baromètre
de la santé
moi j'ai dit souvent que quand j'ai
quitté le département
le département était à cette année cette
année ennemis même vous pouvez tomber
sur un département une agglomération
même cabinet qu'il a comparé à un
département et lemercier et les mêmes
chiffres qui donnent le baromètre de la
santé de la collectivité à l'époque les
cris subway ses amis qui étaient pour
les mêmes amis aujourd'hui d'ailleurs et
bien disait que le département était
enfin il dit ce qui était avancé les
départements j'avais 15 mai
quand on est responsable de quelque
chose en politique on est responsable de
ses actes
c'est votre effectivement je les connais
ils ont les premiers nos deux amis sont
ici ont voté tous les budgets de 10
heures le gouvernement a passé les
dotations de l'état mais bien sûr mais
camille on sait combien le budget de
l'agglo mais bien sûr un million des
multi donc brûler ça fait cela dure la
situation la situation est sûr que
l'état s'est mal comporté s'est mal
comporté sur tous les gouvernements et
tous membres il n'y a pas eu de la
tournée on peut tous être d'accord mais
c'est la mauvaise gestion elle vient pas
de là c'est simplement que la ville des
beaux et bons coups s'est servie de
l'agglo comme une banque pendant des
années ça n'était pas choisi les projets
mais si elle a choisi les projets là
vous aviez quand ce n'est pas le cas et
c'est et ces messieurs qui étaient là à
l'époque avec comme principales
activités politiques de lever le bras et
donc ils ont levé le bras à tous et
aujourd'hui on lève les bras quand on
dit oui un oui et non parce que moi j'ai
levé le bras pour dire non donc à
l'époque on était quand même quelques
jeunes et donc aujourd'hui la situation
de notre agglomération effectivement
elle est très préoccupante et celui qui
va arriver aux responsabilités de
l'agglomération va avoir un sérieux
problème
justement en parlant il ya il ya une
compétence transport qui est importante
sur le bassin lédonien par exemple
madame rêve et revit vous vous voulez
que les transports soient gratuits
pourquoi alors non seulement on veut que
les transports ça soit gratuit
mais on veut aussi une augmentation du
cadencement de la fréquence de passage
des bus et une âme et des parcours revue
pour une meilleure un meilleur maillage
territorial pourquoi vous voulez tout
simplement alors vous voulez le beurre
et l'argent du beurre
ouais tout simplement parce que quand on
a été voir la population partout dans
tous les quartiers de lons le saunier ce
que nous ont dit les gens c'est le trou
alors sapin très combien bus est trop
cher et surtout il ne convient pas à nos
besoins mais ça ça coûterait combien le
transport gratuit sur lons le saunier
alors la gratuité du des bus elle est
financée par les économies qu'on peut
réaliser en la mettant en place il ya
plusieurs villes qui ont été pilote qui
l'ont mis en place actuellement la
billetterie la billetterie à lons le
saunier correspond à quel pourcentage du
budget alors je
n'ai pas cette information là ce que je
sais et colisée de 7 10% montrent que
183 millions c'est entre les 180 200
mille euros
je voulais je voulais que ce soit madame
sylvie ses hommes
c'est gratuit mais vous allez
l'autofinancer quoi c'est ça que vous
voulez dire j'ai pas bien compris on a
regardé là où ça s'est fait sur
différentes tailles de ville si cela
était faisable et en fait les économies
que nous faisons quand on rend le bus
gratuits et notamment l agence les
tickets nombreux rôles permettent de
financer la gratuité des bus ce qui est
de l'augmentation du cadencement et du
maillage territorial la taxe transport
qui il ne semble bien a été augmentée il
ya deux ans à peine deux ans il a la
technique important il ya en 2018 permet
le financement je trouve à demander
cette augmentation va demander à
monsieur ravier qui est un petit peu en
retard en termes de temps de minutes et
deux secondes vous est ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre le transport gratuit
je pense que ce projet de transport tout
voir la globalité mais moi ce que je
voudrais mettre en place sur la vie de
lons un véritable plan de déplacement
urbain qui prennent en compte les
différents modes de déplacement à pied à
vélo en voiture et en bus est ce que
nous disent les lédoniens dans les
réunions de quartier auquel on on les a
conviés c'est qu'ils veulent des pistes
cyclables sécurisées des pistes
cyclables qui inquiète des continuités
knievel des trottoirs en bon état et
qu'ils soient propres
il veut aussi des arrêts temporaires des
arrêts minutes pour aller faire leurs
courses facilement et au niveau des
transports collectifs
il ne manque pas la gratuité il demande
plus de bus et plus de lignes de bus
d'ailleurs à une bouillotte qui est vice
présidente en charge de la mobilité au
niveau de l'agglomération est aussi sur
cette même dynamique
donc pas de gratuité il il existe déjà
un tarif on va dire solidaire tarifs
progressifs qui existe puisqu'il sait
pas les 2 8 euros à 25 euros
l'abonnement mensuel
bien sûr qu'il faut maintenir ce tarif
est peut-être le faire évoluer pour dans
certaines situations particulières
encore aller plus loin
mais je pense que l'argent qu'on le
récupère par le biais de l'adula vente
des tickets peut servir justement à
augmenter ce cadencement de même que le
versement transport
même si actuellement le versement
transport a été utilisé pour créer des
voies douces ce qui est aussi dans le
domaine de la transition écologique une
bonne chose mais à terme le versement
transport devrait servir à améliorer la
circulation des bus sur l'agglomération
transport gratuit monsieur bois monsieur
est vous êtes plutôt qu'aux abonnements
à 12 euros par an parce que la gratuité
n'est pas logique puisque tout a un coût
dans les services publics art même
symbolique donc 12 euros par an ça
permet d'inciter les citoyens à utiliser
les transports publics
et puis à désengorger le centre-ville
effectivement fera des économies de
gestion parce qu'on passera de 15 tarif
à un sol c'est bien plus simple pour
gérer les recettes annuelles c'est à peu
près cent dix mille euros hors taxes
annuelles nous on pense qu'on arrivera à
avoir une recette de 60000 euros annuels
c'est alors l'impossible monsieur bois
n'a pas l'air des débats vous êtes
totalement possible bien sûr que sinon
c'est pas ça le chiffre annoncé 6,4 c
180 quelques minutes
alors moi par rapport à la gratuité des
transports pour ou contre je vais je
vais être cohérent par rapport à logique
nous ne voulons pas augmenter les impôts
sur la vie et sur éclat la compétence
transport est une compétence agglo alors
on nous dit il n'y a pas de moyens pour
l'agglomération est en fait les
transports gratuits
c'est du moins le budget c'est le sens
mineur en jeu deux cent mille euros
on est sur cette logique là et
effectivement les enquêtes le montrent
et il faut mettre plus d'horaires plus
de densification de des bus voilà ce qui
attend du courant desaulniers ce n'est
pas la gratuité qui a tendu juste un mot
sur les 8 es mon choix pour le réputé
je suis pour la gratuité et je suis
étonné tous mes petits camarades le
prennent sur l'aspect uniquement
financiers aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le sujet c'est on parle de
transition écologique tout le monde
écolo maintenant donc le sujet c'est ça
c'est que si on veut je perds ni surtout
quand vous voulez monsieur
moi j'ai pris des mesures j'ai agi j'ai
pas commenter petit nombre d'ailleurs
souvent j'ai relu les comptes rendus des
conseils municipaux pas longtemps sur
les ags perdition mais je suis depuis
plus longtemps vous il devait bien plus
longtemps vous et je suis à votre
disposition pour vous le prouver
sans aucun problème mais sur cet aspect
là qui est important et dans toutes les
villes où ça a été fait il ya une
fréquentation qui augmente d'une manière
exponentielle et ça c'est on veut c'est
ça l'important par rapport à
l'environnement c'est que les gens
prennent plus le bus et je pourrais
mourir je ne compte jamais le bus mais
que les gens prennent plus le bus à côté
a plutôt que la voiture et on constate
c'est pas c'est même pas un choix
on constate que quand c'est gratuit ils
prennent beaucoup plus le bus donc il
faut aller dans cette direction
donc les mêmes choses pardon et si ravis
que les études ne disent pas la même
chose il ya des secteurs où il ya eu le
bus gratuit a été mis en place et il n'y
a pas eu l'augmentation attendue ce que
les gens veulent c'est surtout une
augmentation pour que ça fonctionne il
intéresser des fous rires une
augmentation de la fréquentation des bus
et que le réseau bus soit floue et
encaissé une baisse d'un point en direct
donc les verts sont contre le voulait
une baisse d'impôts indirects
c'est plus que plus facile mais
effectivement les dom les citoyens
demandent plus de cadencement de pouvoir
avoir une dessert dans les zones
d'activités et c'est effectivement on
s'engage à travers ce budget annexe le
transport de financer un plan climat le
vélo en cinq ans qui permettent d'avoir
une continuité des pistes cyclables une
signalisation verticale et horizontale
optimale tu es même une maison de la
mobilité qui serait positionné à la gare
qui favorise l'intermodalité
donc oui pour non pas la gratuité des
transports
mais un abonnement à 12 euros par an ça
me semble équitable juste un mot jusqu'à
ma salle à consulter sur cette idée que
nous quand on rend un service gratuit
c'est une mauvaise chose parce que les
gens ne se rendent plus compte que ça a
un coût moi j'appelle ça du mépris de
classe
croyez vous vraiment que les gens qui
n'ont pas aujourd'hui les moyens que ce
soit de manger à la cantine ou de
prendre le bus ne savent pas que ça
coûte de l'argent puis le nam continuer
eh bien il ya un euro il ya pour 500
familles 1 euro par enfant
c'est trop cher monsieur est monsieur
bouadi 400000 euros par an pour un euro
la tromper une fois ils se trompent une
deuxième fois ça va passer maintenant
avant la conclusion vous aurez 40
minutes chacun pour 42 40 40 secondes
elle commençait à maccarone seconde en
j'aurais déjà qu'on parle un tout petit
peu politique pour savoir s'il ya des
accords de désistements donc entre entre
vous entre les uns et les autres
vous êtes issus tous les deux de la même
majorité
vous êtes donc vous vous et monsieur
pélissard vous a retiré sa d'aider votre
des dégâts si vite et si ce durant le
mandat c'est une coutume moi je ferais
exactement comme vous est-ce que entre
vous deux il est possible que s'il en
arrive devant l'autre il ya un accord de
désistement entre vous deux monsieur wet
est ce que si vous êtes deuxièmes vous
appeler à voter pour monsieur bois j'ai
réussi j'envisage pas de deuxième chance
est facile comme a les mots c'est pas
facile comme une réponse nous on est on
a un programme
on a un projet pour cette prochaine
mandature mais aussi pour les dix
prochaines années
aujourd'hui on va défendre notre projet
auprès des concitoyens à montrer qu'il
est le meilleur et au soir des résultats
on verra mais aujourd'hui mais
j'envisage pas des deuxièmes monsieur
bois si vous êtes derrière monsieur est
est ce qu'il ya une possibilité que vous
appeliez à voter pour duick vous
fusionnez et c'est de faire la même
réponse que monsieur non une fois il a
utilisé un joker c'est pour toutes les
missions on est on défend un projet ou
non un projet dont on a un projet
d'avenir pour faire bouger la ville
on va jusqu'au bout et puis on espère
bien gagner avec ce projet madame revit
vous par rapport aux ac 4 messieurs sur
le plateau alors si vous êtes derrière
tout le monde non pas de consignes à la
haute
moi je la liste que je touche je suis
tête de liste et les portés par le
peuple lédonien ils ont peut-être
l'argent nous avons la force du nombre
on sera pas derrière tout le monde mais
en l'occurrence
si nous avions voulu faire des choses
avec des partir de lundi entre vous
alors nous l'aurions fait dès le début
si nous nous présentons devant les
lédoniens le 15 mars c'est on va laisser
quelque chose de mal et c'est encore un
petit peu de temps a cédé 2 messieurs
donc comme je le disais au début de
cette émission christophe perny vous
êtes un ancien socialiste vous avez été
aussi à la république en marche dessus
graviers conduit une liste alors que lui
n'a pas d'appartenance politique ps pcf
et d'europe écologie les verts
si vous êtes derrière monsieur ravier
est ce que vous pouvez vous entendre
avec lui ont pas et ne l'utilisé pas un
argument que monsieur et mais qu'est ce
que vous croyez franchement quand vous
posez votre question que je lui aurais
pour moi c'est ça non mais on est dans
une petite ville donc tout le monde se
parle voilà hier on se croise on discute
on parle finalement tout donc on va
jouer la première mi temps et puis à la
mi temps on fera le point et on le fera
l'équipe pour la musique
vous voyez comment les choses vous mais
moi c'est pareil j'ai un projet une
équipe je suis c'est moi qui mène ce
projet on verra le soir du premier tour
ce qui se passe on verra avec vous alors
à les uns et les autres on vous suivra
alors donc comme je disais tout à
l'heure on va donner dont 40 secondes à
chacun des candidats pour conclure
l'ordre pour parer à la fin de cette
émission c'est le même qu'au début et on
va commencer par vous gens ivres aviez
donc la question c'est quelles sont les
arguments que vous développez pour que
les lédoniens vote pour vous vous avez
40 secondes et là je regarde vraiment le
chronomètre et bien je crois que la
ville n'est pas prête à rentrer dans le
21e siècle et notamment de la transition
écologique et je veux de la ville soit
plus écologique en rénovant l'habitat
notamment en isolant les logements pour
rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux habitants
ne veut qu'elle soit plus écologique en
améliorant le transport notamment les
transports doux je vais aussi qu'elle
soit plus solidaire en défendant le
service public notamment le service
public hospitalier
on le voit bien actuellement et ce qui
se passe au niveau national c'est le
pilier de la santé je veux aussi mettre
en place une mutuelle communal pour que
les plus démunis aient accès aux soins
est facilement et puis aussi je vais une
ville avec plus de démocratie où les
habitants puisse s'accaparer les grands
projets je mettrai en place de projets
participatifs dans chaque quartier
et sur les grands projets structurants
bien sûr on ira aux côtés des habitants
pour leur expliquer notre projet et voir
avec eux ce qu'il pense de la situation
christophe bois c'est à vous vous avez
compris ce soir que mon projet que notre
projet le projet de vivre l'once est un
projet responsable qui est basée sur la
volonté de faire bouger la ville je
conduis cette campagne avec sofiane ben
ce qui est unie expérimenté avec sophie
nous avons monté une liste qui nous
ressemble et qui rassemble différentes
sensibilités
nous notre objectif il est peut se
résumer sur 3.1 nous souhaitons envie
d'un trois points gratuits de libérer
des moyens de fonctionnement sur
sécurité la propreté réanimation nous
souhaitons et je dédie à assez fortement
ce soit ne pas augmenter les impôts ni à
la ville ni à l'agglomération
ce sera le mot de la fin christophe
perny vous avez 30 secondes vous
seulement puisque vous avez été très
bavard
rapidement vous avez vous avez déjà
perdu deux autres listes elle incarne le
vrai changement
nous sommes comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure libre libre des parties nous
sommes libres du passé nous n'avons pas
de lien avec l'ancienne majorité
et puis nous avons une liste qui est
représentative qui porte les valeurs de
lons le saunier avec des compétences
particulières aux à volonté un directeur
la banque de france qui va apporter son
expertise économique nous avons des
figures de la culture du sport et puis
vous nous avons mon expérience de
gestion d'une grande collectivité comme
le département et c'est pour ça que
notre liste qui s'appelle gémenos et
bien va dans les années qui viennent
porter toutes ses valeurs et tout ses
réussites à venir janet 40 secondes
aussi pour vous non c'est un carrefour
de son histoire nous avons un projet qui
s'articule autour de la gouvernance
démocratique on souhaite associer les
citoyens pour bâtir ce projet et le
mettre en oeuvre
nous souhaitons aussi développer
l'économie qui est la richesse de notre
territoire tout en maîtrisant la
préservation des services publics et en
premier lieu effectivement l'hôpital et
l'accès aux soins pour nos concitoyens
et on est très orienté sur la maîtrise
de l'environnement la préservation de
l'environnement en requalifiant les
logements vacants notamment avec une
filière d'isolation à la base du chanvre
nous avons une équipe jeune
expérimenté multiculturelle qui
représente tous les quartiers
expérimentés et de toutes générations
long semé
de redevenir cette capitale du jura les
citoyens les lédoniens mérite d'avoir
cette ville où on rêve on a envie de
s'épanouir
géraldine leur vie alors la liste l'ours
en commun porte l'exigence populaire de
plus de démocratie nous avons un
engagement c'est de faire que le peuple
de l'once soit décisionnaires à chaque
fois qu'un projet sera mis en place
notre équipe municipale proposera à la
population des projets et ils décideront
nous ferons ensemble et pour proposer
nous aurons des axes de travail
prioritaires qui seront la santé le
logement l'emploi l'écologie
fort de ces quatre axes la nous
proposerons aux lédonien de choisir ce
qui sera mis en place
très bien merci madame revit alors je
vous propose maintenant de regarder un
panneau avec tous les candidats qui sont
en lice à lons le saunier donc pour
cette élection municipale premier tour
le 15 mars 2e tour le 22 mars
ils ont été classés par ordre
alphabétique alors madame messieurs
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à cette
émission je vous rappelle que mercredi
prochain le 4 mars place à belfort et à
dole débat animé par jérémie chevreuil
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver le
mercredi suivant le 11 mars pour un gros
plan cette fois ci sur besançon et
vesoul
et puis vous n'oubliez pas le dimanche 8
mars à 11h25
ce sera les municipales à saint claude
dans le jura
voilà merci de votre attention merci
madame merci messieurs
et puis bonne fin de soirée à vous tous
au revoir
[Musique]